en español bueno preguntarme en primer
lugar qué le espera a juan orlando
hernández en eeuu
[Música]
finalmente nos vivienda que es un juicio
que aparentemente y por lo que se ha
sabido que la abundancia de pruebas
y documentales testimoniales que podrían
llevar finalmente a una sentencia
similar a la que a un proceso similar al
que llegó su hermano tony atrás siempre
sentenciado a cadena perpetua por
delitos que tanto
y cuéntenos qué repercusiones ha tenido
este caso tanto en las esferas políticas
y como entre la ciudadanía
definitivamente
es algo que lo ha estado
[Música]
muchísimo
el presidente calificado como un
autócrata
hizo muy evidente la corrupción que
lideraba desde destrucción como
presidente pero anteriormente también
como presidente del congreso y una
posición de liderazgo en materia de
corrupción y fundida de picota y ella ha
sido un político reacción nacional
convirtiendo lógicamente al país en país
estaba en un estado completamente
corrupción
esto es un motivo de celebración hay una
parte por supuesto de la ciudadanía que
aún defiende y piensa que orlando
hernández
es inocente sin embargo no se puede
decir en la mayoría de la población
recibe la extradición pues con con mucha
alegría con mucha satisfacción y una
esperanza de que por fin aunque no sea
en la justicia hondureña pero que por
fin cuando antes va a pagar menos por
los delitos en los que
a nivel político esto presionará un
debate bastante grande lógicamente esto
no es un producto de la justicia
hondureña por lo tanto lógicamente no se
puede pensar que la justicia hondureña
como tal ha dado un paso adelante porque
lógicamente no es un resultado de un
mejoramiento ni de la transparencia de
la justicia en el país es el resultado
de esa elección